[Music]  motional is launching its first Robo  taxi service right here in Las Vegas you  can now ride in its all-electric Robo  taxis through Uber Services now the  rides come with a vehicle operator but  the company is working towards launching  driverless service in 2023 now for now  the services will be free while the  company collects feedback so stay tuned  for that all right that's not the only  automatic ride uh automatic ride show  here in Las Vegas Zoots is testing its  first autonomous ride service on the Las  Vegas Strip it says the vehicles use  sensors to see its surroundings from all  directions and up to 150 meters well  right now the sensors are being tested  on regular vehicles but the goal is to  eventually use all electric vehicles